do you have a sense
of what is that base layer physical
reality you have
like uh so you have these attempts at
the theories of everything
the very very small of like strength
theory
or what um stephen wolfram talks about
with a hyper grass these are these tiny
tiny tiny tiny objects and then there is
more like
quantum mechanics
that's talking about objects that are
much larger but still very very very
tiny do you have a sense of where the
tiniest thing is that is like
at the lowest level the turtle at the
very bottom you have a sense
i don't think you can talk about where
it is because space is emerging over the
activity of these things so space
the coordinates only exist in relation
to the
things other things and so you could in
some sense abstract it into locations
that can hold information and
trajectories that the information can
take between the different locations and
this is how we construct our notion of
space
yeah and
physicists
usually have a notion of space that is
continuous
and this is a point where i
tend to agree with people like stephen
wolfram who are very skeptical of the
geometric notions
i think that geometry is the dynamics of
too many parts to count and
when there are no infinities if there
were two infinities you would be running
into contradictions which is in some
sense what uh goodwill and during
discovered
in response to hilbert's call
so there are no infinities there are no
infinities fake there is unboundedness
but if you have a language that talks
about infinity at some point the
language is going to contradict itself
which means it's no longer valid in
order to deal with infinities and
mathematics you have to postulate the
existence
initially you cannot construct the
infinities and that's an issue right you
cannot build up an infinity from zero
but uh in practice you never do this
right when you perform calculations you
only look at the dynamics of too many
parts to count
and uh usually these
numbers are not that large they're not
googles or something the big
the infinities that we are dealing with
in our universe are mathematically
speaking
relatively small integers
and
still
what you're looking at is dynamics where
um
a trillion things behave uh similar to
100 trillion things or
something that is very very large
because they're converging and these
convergent dynamics these operators this
is what we deal with when we are doing
the geometry right geometry is stuff
where we can pretend that it's
continuous because uh as if we subdivide
the space sufficiently
fine grained uh these things approach a
certain dynamic and this approached
dynamic that is what we mean by it but i
don't think that infinity would work so
to speak that you would know the last
digit of pi and that you have a physical
process that rests on knowing the last
digit of pi
yeah that that could be just a peculiar
quark of human cognition that we like
discrete discrete makes sense to us
infinity doesn't
so in terms of our intuitions no the
issue is that everything that we think
about uh needs to be expressed in some
kind of mental language not not
necessarily a natural language but some
kind of mathematical language that your
neurons can speak that refers to
something in the world and what we have
discovered is that
uh we cannot construct a notion of
infinity without running into
contradictions which means that such a
language is no longer valid
and i suspect this is what uh made
pythagoras so unhappy when somebody came
up with the notion of irrational numbers
before it was time right there's this
miss that he had this person killed when
he blapped out the secret that not
everything can be expressed as a ratio
between two numbers but there are there
are numbers between the ratios the world
was not ready for this and i think he
was right that has confused
mathematicians
uh
very seriously because these numbers are
not values they're functions
right so you can calculate these
functions to a certain degree of
approximation but you cannot pretend
that pi has actually a value
pi is a function that would generally
approach this value to some degree
but nothing in the world rests on
knowing pi
uh how much does how important is this
distinction between discrete and
continuous uh
for you to get to the because there's a
i mean
in discussion of your favorite flavor of
the theory of everything there's a few
on the table
so there's string theory there's a
particular
there's uh
lube quantum gravity which focuses on
one particular unification
uh there's
there's just a bunch of favorite flavors
of different people trying to
propose a theory of everything uh eric
weinstein
and a bunch of people throughout history
and then of course stephen wolfram who i
think is one of the only people doing a
discrete
oh no there's a bunch of physicists who
do this right now and okay like
toefl and thomasello and
the
digital physics is something that is i
think growing in popularity
but uh
the
main reason why this is interesting is
um
uh because it uh it's important
sometimes to settle disagreements i
don't think that you need infinity s or
at all you never needed them
you can always deal with very large
numbers and you can do it with limits
right we are fine with doing that you
don't need any kind of infinity you can
build your computer algebra systems just
as well without believing in infinity in
the first place so you're okay with
limits
yeah so basically a limit means that
something is behaving pretty much the
same
if you make the number larger
right because it's converging to a
certain value and at some point the
difference becomes negligible and you
can no longer measure it
and in this sense you have things that
if have you an angon which is has enough
corners then it's going to behave like a
circle at some point right and it's only
going to be in some kind of esoteric
thing that cannot exist in the physical
universe that you would be talking about
this perfect circle and now it turns out
that it also wouldn't work in
mathematics because you cannot construct
mathematics that has infinite resolution
without running into contradictions
so uh that is itself not that important
because we never did that right it's
just a thing that some people thought we
could
and this leads to confusion
you